il aura fallu aujourd'hui six heures au
greffier de la cour d'assises de paris
pour lire l'acte d'accusation c'est à
dire la liste des faits reprochés à
jacques mesrine est à trois complices
auparavant en fin de matinée le gangster
avaient été amenés au palais dans un
fourgon sévèrement gardée il y a
d'ailleurs le service d'ordre des grands
jours autour du palais de justice
jacques mesrine reste tout de même
titulaire si l'on peut dire paul lefèvre
de deux évasions spectaculaires
puis la première le 21 9 71 mesrine a
réussi à s'échapper d'une prison
canadienne des pénitenciers
saint-vincent-de-paul avait établi la
table forteresse et un f3 véritable soit
permis d'ailleurs ensuite de dénoncer à
la presse là bas au canada les
conditions épouvantables de détention
dans cette prison qui est d'ailleurs été
fermé en suite et la deuxième évasion
c'est en france la première du genre qui
ensuite inspiré jean charles gil ok elle
remonte au 6 juin 73 mesrine c'était
vallée du palais de justice de compiègne
il avait fait caché par un complice
harry volver dans les toilettes et il
s'est enfui en prenant un juge comme
otages pour sortir du palais de justice
aujourd'hui évidemment il ne fait pas
peur il est désarmé et c'est revolver se
trouve dans la tablette envers des
pièces à conviction devant lui il les
regarde de temps à autre alors dans le
box mesrine apparaît très convenable
tout à fait comme il faut et les grands
bm large gamme être au monde avec une
moustache un poil voyous et une tête
ronde avec les yeux qui bouge tout le
temps sur mesrine sans sa salle et
commence à entamer un dialogue un
dialogue muet avec les journalistes
devant lui par-dessus ses avocats qui
fait le dossier comme si elle ne
connaissait pas c'est assez amusant mais
qu'il manque une femme dans le box elle
qui est apparemment sa compagne de
cavale oui là c'est dommage jeune
schneider est sérieusement malade elle
sera jugée plus tard son cas était 10
juin représente un côté mystérieux
disons plutôt sympathique du caractère
de mesrine c'est à dire la femme celle
qu'on respecte aussi celle qu'on protège
pour l'instant donc il est aux côtés de
mesrine trois hommes deux tout à fait à
côté de lui et le troisième un peu plus
à l'écart à droite c'est le troisième
qui a permis l'arrestation de mesrine et
donc il ya un certain contentieux entre
les deux alors mesrine va être jugé par
cinq hommes et quatre femmes dont l'une
tout à fait à droite et comme un petit
chat qui regarde un gros chien actuelle
et ce sont ces jurés qui vont décider si
mesrine va réussir ou non à faire son
procès spectacle bien le feuilleton
mesrine commence mon jour retrouvant
régulièrement polis
m